yeah it's funny
and you you you talk about that the
current sort of decentralized world d5
but
decentralized services world is
primarily just tokens
and it's basically just financial
transactions
the kind of thing the reason why it's
super exciting the kind of thing you're
doing with chain link and oracle
networks
is that you can basically open up the
whole world of services
to into this kind of uh
decentralized smart contract world
i mean you're talking about
just orders of magnitude greater impact
financially and just
socially and philosophically
are there interesting near-term and
long-term applications that excite you
yeah there's there's a lot that excites
me and that is how i think about it that
it's not just about we made a
decentralized oracle network
it's about we made a decentralized
service or collection of services that's
going from hundreds to thousands
and then people are able to build the
hybrid smart contracts which i think
will redefine what our industry is about
because for example for the people that
only learned about blockchains through
the
lens of nfts they understand blockchains
through nfts
not through speculative tokens or
bitcoins right and i think that
that that will continue i i think the
use cases that excite me
they vary between the developed uh
market that developed worlds economies
and
emerging markets i think in the
developed world
what you will see is that transparency
creating
a level a new level of information for
how
markets work and the risk that is in
markets and
kind of the dynamics that put the global
financial system
at systemic financial risk like 2008 and
my hope is that
all of this infrastructure will will
soften the boom
and bust cycles by making information
immediately available to all market
participants
which is by the way what all market
participants want except for the very
very very small minority
that are able to game the system and
their benefit and benefit from booms but
avoid busts because of their asymmetric
access to information which really
everybody should have and which this
technically solves
i think in the process of doing that and
which is happening i think right about
now
you see a polishing of the technology
such that it can be made available to
emerging markets
and on a personal level i feel that
the emerging markets will benefit much
more from this technology
just like the emerging markets benefit
much more from the internet
or from those you know fifty dollar
android phones that people can have
because it's it's such a massive shift
in how people's lives work right
i have always had access to books and a
library which has been fantastic and
very important
but there are places in the world where
people don't have libraries
but they now they have the internet and
a 50 android phone
and they can watch the same stanford
lecture that i watch i mean that's kind
of mind-blowing
realistically right they they just went
from zero to one in a very very dramatic
way
i think all of these smart contracts
and in in my case i think the one that i
seem to keep coming back to is crop
insurance
where partly because it doesn't have a
tokenization component partly because
it's actually much more important than
than it might seem um what is crop
insurance
right so exactly so so this this is this
is the nature of why it's sometimes
hard to see the full value of what our
industry does because it solves all
these kinds of back-end problems that we
don't have right so
crop insurance is if i own a farm and it
doesn't rain i get an
insurance payout so i don't need to
close down my farm
because if it didn't rain i don't have
crops right
so people in the developed world can't
get
crop insurance and there's all kinds of
systems that basically pay them out and
then they can argue with the legal
with the insurance company if they don't
get paid out properly and whatever
and this allows people to smooth out
risk
in fact a lot of the global options
markets were about this
right they were initially about people
selling their produce or their crops
ahead of time
so that if there was a risk of drought
they weren't impacted by it
right and that's where a lot of options
trading and all this kind of stuff came
from
even though it's now turned into this
kind of global casino
but in the emerging market there are
there are literally people that
if they don't have rain for two seasons
they need to close down their farm and
become a migrant worker of some kind
and now they have a 50 android phone
where they can read wikipedia
but they're still decades away from an
insurance company coming to their
geography and offering them insurance
because their local legal system simply
doesn't allow that type of thing to
exist
no insurance company is going to go and
create insurance entity and offer them
insurance because
you know the levels of fraud and the
ability to resolve that fraud through
courts would just not exist
so now these people have to wait for
decades to have this very basic form of
financial protection
or or something like a bank account even
and with this technology they don't
right so with this technology if i have
a 50 android phone
and the smart contract has data from
satellites or weather stations about the
weather conditions
in the geography that my farm is in i
can i can
put value into the smart contract and
the smart contract will automatically
pay me out
back pay me back out at my android phone
and and guess what
i just leapfrogged past my corrupt
government not being able to provide
a legal infrastructure to create
insurance i just leapfrog
past dealing with insurance companies
that'll probably price gouge me
and and and and often not pay out and i
leapfrogged into the world
of hyper reliable um kind of
guaranteed smart contract outcomes that
are as good or in many cases better than
what farmers in all parts of other parts
of the world have
and this type of dynamic for the
emerging markets of creating a way for
people to control
and manage risk in their economic life i
think extends way past insurance it
extends to them having bank accounts to
combat local inflation
it extends to them being able to sell
their goods on the global free market of
global trade without middlemen
it extends to all these things that we
don't really care about right because
we're not farmers
but our unbelievably impactful for
people that
don't have a bank account and their
inflation rate in their country is
double digits
or their farm completely depends our
reign or their livelihood completely
depends on their ability to sell
goods and they can't sell those goods
because there's a middleman
who essentially controls all the trust
relationships
but now now we have the internet and
smart contracts and that might not have
to be the case
in in in the next five or ten years yeah
so that definitely has a quality of
life impact on the particular farmer's
life but i suspect it
has a huge like down the line ripple
effect on the whole supply chain
so if you think about farmers but
any other people that produce
things that are part of a large
like logistics network like supply chain
network
that means when you increase reliability
you sort of increase uh transparency and
control
but like where any one node in that
supply chain
network can formalize
the way it operates in its agreements
with others
then you could just have a very
like at scale transformative effect
on how people that down the line
use the services that you provide the
products that you create
operate so like it's almost hard to um
imagine the the possible ways it might
transform the world
i i wonder how much friction there is in
the system i guess
currently that uh smart contracts might
remove
that's so that's a that's almost unknown
you can sort of hypothesize and stuff
but i wonder
i've seen enough bureaucracy in my world
in my life
to know that smart contracts in many
cases would remove bureaucracy
and i wonder how the world will be once
you remove much of the bureaucracy
coming from the soviet union where i
just have seen
the life sucked out
of the innovative spirit of human nature
by bureaucracy i wonder you know
the kind of amazing world that could be
created once bureaucracy is removed
yeah i i think it's i think it's
fascinating how the world
can can evolve i i think this extends a
lot further than people think into many
many different parts of the global
economy
it might start with nfts for art or it
might start with defy
right or it might start with fraud proof
ad networks next
we don't know what it's going to go to
next but i think the implication
of people being in a system of contracts
that holds them accountable and
guarantees contractual outcomes
regardless of a local legal system is
something that i think extends
you know to the supply chain you can
prove that goods were sourced in an
ethical way and you can prove that in a
way that can't be gamed
that'll change buying power and supplier
power and
and how people produce goods that we all
consume and then on the political level
i personally think that in a number of
decades we could literally be in a place
where politicians can commit to a
certain set of smart contract
kind of budget definitional kind of
results for example
you know we discovered oil i promise as
a politician i'm going to take the oil
and i'm going to redistribute it to all
of you well that's wonderful that's a
great idea
sounds very nice when you when you're
running for office why don't we codify
that in a smart contract
and why don't we put those conditions
very solidly on a blockchain and
then once once you you you've been
elected
we'll just turn that one on and it'll
it'll it'll distribute the money just
like you said
and everything will be fine i i
personally think that this
new level of systems that allows
trustworthy collaboration
between everybody between supply chain
partners ad network users the financial
system
insurance companies and farmers all of
these are just interactions
that require a trusted entity
or in this case a trusted piece of code
to orchestrate the interaction
in the way that everyone agrees
yeah one of the things that makes the
united states fascinating is the
founding documents
and it's fascinating to think of us
moving into the new in the 21st century
to a a digital version of that so the
constitution
a smart constitution no offense to the
uh paper constitution but and i would
change
that would have transformative effects
on politicians and
governments holding people accountable
oh man i that's so that's so exciting
to think that we might
enforce accountability
through the smart contract process
exactly why can't that happen
anything that we could codify into a
smart contract and anything that we all
agree
is the way thing the world should work
and then anything that we can get proof
about
right anything that a system somewhere
could tell us happened
those are the pieces of the puzzle right
we need a trusted piece of code we need
to have
agreement that that's how the world
should work and we need a system that
will tell that trusted piece of code
what happened
as long as we have those three things we
can theoretically codify
any set of agreements about uh about
about anything
where those three properties uh take
hold
i wonder if you can apply that to like
military conflict and so on
uh recently uh the biden announced that
we're going to pull off from
afghanistan after 20 20 years in the war
i wonder there's a lot of tobacco
debacles
around war in afghanistan and invasion
of iraq all those kinds of things
i wonder if that was instead formulated
as a smart contract
like uh that might have actually huge
impact on the way we do conflict so you
think of uh
smart contract as a as a kind of win-win
situation
where you're doing like financial
transactions or something like that
but you could see that also about
military conflict or like
whenever two nations are attention with
each other
different scales of conflict that you
can have
conflict codified
and that would potentially resolve
conflict much faster
because there's honesty transparency and
control within that conflict because
there's conflict in this world
and i i again very very inspiring to
think about
the the kind of effects it might have on
the on
on the negative kinds of contracts and
the tense
painful kinds of contracts i i haven't
thought about that as much it's actually
kind of scary the stuff you're
you're thinking through now with like
the war contracts or something you know
that's not in the white paper we don't
have anything about war contracts or
anything again this is the the russian
uh
we're both russian but i'm a little more
russian uh in the suffering side
maybe i read way too much dostoevsky and
uh military kind of ideas but
anyway holding politicians accountable
in all forms i think it's really
powerful
you